I want to start with congratulations the
footage you showed earlier today looks
spectacular
um I cannot wait to see the finished
film
um I have a lot of questions but I'm
going to start with probably the most
important thing uh I know that Guillermo
likes to take home things when he makes
a movie when he builds anything for a
film he needs to own it he'll make three
of something so he can have something I
know the way he works so for for both of
you what did you each borrow from sets
and Guillermo how do you have any room
left in your home to take anything well
the real estate is my second passion if
I can I sell a house and buy I want a
little bigger or buy a little apartment
and fill it with Collectibles it is a
slow thing but here the beauty of
animation and this is important because
we are working with many sets
simultaneously you need multiple peoples
of every puppet so there's one for
almost anyone that would want one so if
something disappears yeah yeah no we and
and and in my case it's in my contract
I take one of each and uh one of uh each
said that I that I can accommodate and
you know I think this this is one of the
things that is very
almost compulsively beautiful about this
is that these are real miniature sets
real miniature props real miniature
clothing aged to look like real fabric
this is It's like a dream a dream said
you would have as a kid
yeah I would have to pinch myself every
day going in and you know at one point
we had 60 units
shooting at the same time so but it was
this huge world of miniature sets and
puppets and just being able to walk out
there and experience that every day it's
like you know what more could a kid want
it was just fantastic Mark did you take
home one of everything or what did you
steal
I don't think I want to say
got it I I understand you don't have
anything at all no I got nothing police
reports going in right exactly well I
listen Guillermo if I'm not mistaken you
have been working on trying to make this
Pinocchio for at least 14 years and you
consistently struggled with the
financing and finding someone to to make
the movie so I just want to take a
moment to thank Netflix for not only
your film but for Henry Selleck being
able to also do Wendell wild and and
Champion
um stop motion can you sort of talk
about
days
for summer and and Phil tip at
completing my my God and so on and so on
I mean this I don't think there's ever
been a year in which the competitive uh
moment of Animation is so much a
technique that is as cherished and as
rare and as uh always and on the brink
of Extinction like some motion is
beautiful to see this Renaissance I I
tell you the the reason I I was able to
to feel comfortable is because Netflix
through the almost decade of tales of
Arcadia uh we we developed a
relationship they knew I would deliver
consistently I I was not a guy that
signed something and walked away I was
involved and checking the quality and
the arc and the scripts and the
animatics and everything on the bills of
Arcadia uh and and they said
he's gonna be
is going to be equally faithful with
this and it is not a guy that is going
to come in and out is going to stay with
it and and uh that's the reason we could
make it because this is not this is of a
piece this is not a movie that was done
quote unquote for kids this is a movie
that the family can watch together but
is for me as personal and of a piece
with a pan sniper and Devil's Backbone
and it's about childhood and the world
at war you know and and about the
beautiful and the Terrible Things in
this world and and and uh we could only
make it here and we can only make it now
after as you say about 15 years or more
yeah one of the things about stop-motion
is there's no shot that's easy every
single shot is difficult so but I am
curious
was there one particular shot on this
whether it be through movement of camera
or from uh the length of the the shot
you were trying to pull off that ended
up being exponentially more difficult
yeah well there was there was one shot
yeah when when our uh when spasitura the
monkey comes he leads us to uh meet one
of our of our villains and he comes
through this whole uh circus
carnival rather that's been created and
uh it was a Warner and it was a long
shot and there were lots of Puppets
involved lots of choreography
um lots of action one single shot yeah
it was it took us uh about
two and a half months to set it up and
it took about a month to shoot and and
we went through about three puppets we
destroyed three puppets of Spencer
during that shot and and from the
beginning uh when we were talking about
uh staging with the camera in a more
naturalistic way where the camera moved
and the actors moved and more like you
would stage in live action that was one
of the shots that was singled out from
pre-production we're gonna do it this
one this way and you know it was
searching naturalism not only on the way
we shot with the camera but the the
actors the acting in this movie does not
refer to pantomime and keep posing and
all this language that has been codified
almost to the Emoji point of of being a
repetition of
hip uh poses and we wanted to have
actors that that acted and that what
that were internal they would you could
see them thinking you could see them
emoting and growing and listening and
doing failed acts making mistakes at 24
frames of Animation a second
we made them stumble we made them uh
topple something and pick it up we made
them Edge
etc etc we did a lot of
uh things that this all came out of a
phrase that I'll never forget that
Miyazaki said if you shoot the ordinary
it will be extraordinary
and I think uh that was one of the great
North stars of this movie you know some
of that restraint using some of that
restraint with the characters really uh
it forces the audience to lean in a
little bit more and I think helps them
connect with with these characters in a
more realistic way one of the things
about stop motion again is that every
second costs real money to animate so
can you sort of talk about figuring out
like measuring budget with how long the
movie can be because you know every
minute costs a lot of money yeah well I
I tell you uh one of the things we knew
is that we needed to keep the movie at a
certain range so we we were
aspiring to the greatness and scope and
this the Ambitions were huge Unlimited
on a budget that was limited but the
important thing as we the way we
animated the the the rhythm of the
animation the rhythm of the scenes there
are scenes where the characters sit down
and talk and you can bask in just two
beautiful two shots or or or a wide and
they are acting and you see these things
alive
and we knew that took time for the
animators why don't anyone animate
failed eggs because they consume and he
made our hours and we we had this very
clear from the beginning and then we had
a monkey wrench uh thrown into the
Machinery with kovid and we had to
Wrangle that also who could work what a
distancing keeping the safety of the
team and so forth and all that fiscal
aspect of it uh took a lot every ounce
of uh
uh sort of restrained while we were
completely unrestrained and looking for
excellence yeah absolutely and we had to
trust our animators we had to find the
best of the best
and really communicate with them what
the overall aesthetic of the film was
what the acting style was and then give
them as much Freedom as we possibly
could
want you know as we said once we gave
them the direction we didn't want them
to be afraid there's nothing worse than
a than an animator who's afraid you know
we want them to feel Brave and be able
to make choices because that's what
that's What actors do too and that's how
you get the best out of them and we had
some fabulous animators I think we have
seriously the the greatest of all times
in this movie that are alive and in this
world and we we gave minute instructions
we we have from them minute video
rehearsals of the moment and then after
the dating and agreeing and all that we
said now if you find something else
you're the actor
you're not just following orders you are
making this character live do it and
that really people really responded to
that that note I gotta go I'm just gonna
say I cannot wait to see the finished
film thank you so much for your time
thank you man see you around